thanks to Kimberly there now an
estimated thirty five thousand Syrians
so far displaced by fighting in Aleppo
are being held at the Turkish border
raising concerns about the conditions
they're facing there and tens of
thousands more are expected to arrive at
the border over the coming days if
Russian and Syrian airstrikes continue
well about Cooper is the chair of
Labour's refugee task force and was of
course one of those in the running to
become the party's leader last
september's she's with me now as you can
see and a very good morning to you what
should Britain's response be to this
growing refugee and humanitarian crisis
we need a global response to what's
happening and you're right that what's
happening with Aleppo is deeply worrying
70,000 people reported to have fled
Aleppo as a result of the bombardment by
the Assad government but also by Russian
forces as well and so you obviously the
priority has to be to do anything
possible to try and stabilize the
situation in Syria to get the peace
talks back on track and put whatever
pressure we can on Russia to stop this
bombardment of civilian areas which is
increasing so you know down you've no
doubt then that the Russians are not
just as they say attacking Isis and the
terrorists that they are bombing
civilian areas I think there's clear
evidence that the majority of the
Russian bombardment is not in fact
towards my sis at all despite everything
that they've said and instead is
targeting the small opposition forces
that have been fighting against the
Assad regime and also that they've been
targeting areas where there are
civilians as well which also causes huge
problems and is increasing the number of
refugees so I think the first priority
is its what is the global response to
that what is the peace process response
and then of course the second most
immediate response is what is the
humanitarian aid that is needed
particularly in Turkey we do need turkey
to open their borders to be able to help
those refugees who are at the border now
but of course turkeys already taken two
and a half million refugees within the
country at the moment and so the more
support that they need the better so do
you think then that the EU should take
even more and within the EU that Britain
should be doing more
I do think the Britain needs to do more
yes but it does have to be part of this
global effort so what I think the
government did last week with the the
aid conference was a really important
and you know I've often criticized the
government as part of this on that one I
think they have done the right thing by
putting the aid into the region and also
getting other countries to put aid in as
well because the priority has to be for
most people want to stay close to home
near too serious so they can return of
course we've also got people who have
fled further and you know when when the
rations in the camps were cut last year
in the refugee camps that's what drove a
lot of people into Europe as well so
look Europe is going to have to cope
with more people arriving in the course
of this year we've already seen an
increase this year compared to last year
but it's going to have to be spread
across the content well across the
continent and members of the European
Union and senior members of the European
Union at this point anyway and the
United Kingdom we've got that number of
20,000 over five years perhaps some more
several thousand more unaccompanied
minors but just on absolute numbers do
you think that should be enlarged yes
Whitney's got a true to war well I
originally said well Britain should take
10,000 straight away and that would mean
helping if every city every county
across the country simply supported 10
refugee families that in itself makes
10,000 people you could do that straight
away within a year I'm also said I think
its rights us for us to help the
unaccompanied child refugees because you
know we did that with the
Kindertransport and we know that Europe
all have said 10,000 refugees child
refugees have just disappeared in Europe
probably into the arms of smuggler gangs
of traffickers and even child
prostitution and abuse so I do think
Britain can do more but actually I think
the best way to do that would be for us
to just go around the country I'm asked
communities how many people they could
suggest they would respond positively
because you know judging by the recent
polls how to choose a rather hardening
against even the numbers we are
scheduled to take and I think you're
right people have become more worried I
think part of the reason people have
become more concerned is because they
don't see where's the plan
where is the comprehensive plan across
Europe I think we're still getting my
huge amount of support and if you ask
communities themselves rather just tell
people what to do but ask at tao cities
to come forward and say what they can do
to help you get a huge response you get
church groups mosques faith groups
coming forward wanting to help community
organizations and so on but my arguments
always been this has got to be done with
a plan that involves both sanctuary and
border controls and checks you've got to
have proper systems in place to make
sure there's security checks being done
but also to manage things to have proper
checks at borders not just a Caillat not
just in Greece but right through Europe
as well contrition I mean you know
people are conflating this it's getting
caught up as we all know with
discussions about migration and
immigration should these refugees these
asylum seekers should they be allowed to
work should there be like to establish
themselves in the United Kingdom or when
the time is right hopefully sooner
rather than later they go back to their
country of origin well in other places
what you're talking about is temporary
sanctuary so for example in the Bosnian
crisis a lot of people who we gave
sanctuary to during during that crisis
ended up also returning to Bosnia
afterwards and being able to be part of
rebuilding their country so we know a
lot of people from Syria want to be able
to return and you're only talking about
temporary sanctuary and so I think
you've also got remember refugees is
different from asylum you know
immigration a lot different things and
often we end up conflating the two part
of the reason you need robust checks to
find out are people at refugees or do
they have safe homes that they need to
return to and the immigration rules need
to be enforced you've got to be able to
separate but it would help in terms of
the contribution they can make to the
society they return to which is by its
very nature head out to be rebuilt if
they they got skills acquired skills
here through work through education sure
and once people have been designated as
refugees once they've been through they
have the proper checks then actually
refugees can work so that's all part of
the existing rules and we know I'm not
talked to two Syrian doctors teachers
lawyers
car mechanics business owners you people
have all kinds of trades and skills but
I think begin people will support that
if they know that the proper rules are
in place so it's why I've argued with in
Europe we should also not have the
Schengen system of no border checks
within Europe as well if you had proper
checks within Europe alongside countries
offering sanctuary you can have both
stability and humanity side by side how
much do you think this is going to be an
issue in the referendum mummy what we're
looking at the moment as soon as June do
you think this is going to be the single
main issue I gave them coming commercial
services will be apart of the debate and
I think we've got to be discussing it as
part of the debate because it's such an
important issue but I think what it
shows actually when you're dealing with
something that's such a big global
problem you need countries to work
together I think we would find it much
harder to deal with the refugee crisis
if we were out of Europe we would find
it harder to maintain our border checks
in Calais rather than in Dover that
would cause big challenges for managing
what happens we will also find it harder
to get other countries whether it be
greased whether it be Germany whether it
be other countries across Europe to also
be working together both to put pressure
on the Syrian process but also to be
able to have border checks to have
robust checks in place and to give
sanctuary to countries as well sort of
cosmic school only people listening to
that well here you know your
sophisticated analysis of the careful
checks when it comes to dealing with
migration the definition of refugees of
asylum but then they look at the
pronouncements of the current leadership
in the likes of the Shadow Chancellor he
seems to be getting towards an open
doors policy latest pronouncements on on
no illegal immigration you know there
are no illegal immigrants in the United
Kingdom do you think that's being
reflected your view is being reflected
in the current message from the Labour
leadership what I don't think you can
have open borders and I don't think
we're heading towards the miser because
when you've got I think we have got more
people travelling than ever before but
in the response to that you need to be
able to manage that you need
have a managed ordered system and that's
why you need border controls why you
need border checks and I think they're
going to become more important in future
and they're more important for example
in stopping smuggling gangs in stopping
child exploitation those 10,000 kids
that Europol say have disappeared how
can you even find out which country they
are in if you don't have the border
checks in place to stop those gangs
trafficking kids across borders could do
with your voice in in the Shadow Cabinet
I mean I know you said after the
leadership campaign was personal
political reasons wasn't it you said you
didn't want to serve in the shadow
cabinet or any of those changing for you
well to be honest this is such an
important issue that I'm concentrating
and working on the refugee crisis and
what not just Britain's response should
be but also Britain and Europe's
response and we're promoting a amendment
in the House of Lords in the next few
weeks which is about taking three
thousand child refugees just as we did
for the Kindertransport and Alf dubs who
was himself came here under the
kindertransport and was rescued from the
Holocaust is the Lord that I've been
working with and proposing that so
that's what I'm concentrate I mean it's
just that voice in the shadow cabinet so
therefore reflected at senior levels
because you know you're aware of the
reports that they have been into why
labour lost last May and one of the
reasons coming back at you and we talked
about it before didn't we while you were
in the leadership campaign was not
taking the issue of migration seriously
or being perceived to be in that
position well there you are as we've
discussed here with a very thought out
position but it's not coming from the
top anymore well I think Andy Burnham is
actually now going around the country
wanting to talk to people about wider
issues about immigration and as I've
said I mean I think immigration and ass
I'm you've got to keep them separate but
the issue of our immigration is a really
important one for Britain and we do have
to recognize the concerns that there are
and also the reforms that are needed but
I think that's exactly what Andy's doing
ok but if mr. gorban hits the buffers in
May we've got this series of electoral
tests coming up I mean have you written
offer a future front bench or even
leadership career for good I think right
now I'm concentrating on this I think
that's the right thing for me to do but
look all of us across the party
to be working hard on the the local
elections at the london mayoral election
as well and I'm sure that you know
Jeremy and all the leadership of the
party will be focused on what it is we
need to do in order to win those
elections because you know we that's in
the end is what the Labour Party's for
is to be able to to win elections and to
get power in order to be able to change
the country for people that we need to
stand up for and just after that as we
discussed my be facing an EU referendum
how hard now visibly are you going to be
campaigning for a remain vote and who
with I'll be strongly campaigning for
for us to stay in Europe we have to I
think whether you're talking about
stability of Europe whether you're
talking about dealing with what is that
the Syrian refugee crisis whether you're
talking about jobs my constituency I
talked to that people run the factories
in my constituency who say how important
it is for them to get rid of it I mean
you know Chuck Romano your colleague
says well I'll be happy again this is
too important to have party political
lines i'll i'll be on a platform with
anyone yeah i think we'll all become
penny and i'll become perry and when
we've got Alan Johnson is leading the
labor in campaign but we yeah and answer
motives and will also be obviously be
working with the stronger in campaign as
well of course you've got to and I think
the end I think probably what you've
seen this is sort of bickering and
division and the the out campaign I
think that actually reveals something
deeper which is that in the end they
don't know what they're campaigning for
we know what we're campaigning for which
is yet we want reforms in Europe we've
got to have changes in Europe but we
also know we've got to be part of
European partnership at a time when
there's so many global threats they
divided because they actually haven't a
clue that some of them who want to be
Norway and that means just effectively
being outside having no se but still
paying in still having to abide by
Europe's rules and having no say there's
others you just want to build a wall
around Britain and think we can hide
ourselves in a bunker and have nothing
to do with the outside world that in the
end is why they're fighting about Cooper
great seeing you thank you very much
indeed